you
[Music]
so our next speakers actually maximun
from university of washington and he's
gonna talk about easy learn quickly
mentioned from Microsoft Research and my
adviser bill how from University of
Washington so the motivation for this
work comes from biomedicine we are
looking at increasingly cheaper and
cheaper sequencing technologies that we
use more and more data that is then
being pushed into repositories like gene
expression omnibus or Express that have
billion millions of samples
corresponding to potentially billions of
data points and it's almost 40 terabytes
of data in Express now the trouble
though is that even though the lot of
data is there data annotation is kind of
lacking so this graph shows exclusive
growth on submitted data samples but as
you can see on the bottom the number of
curated samples is very is growing
slowly because they're doing it manually
so we want to automate this curation of
scientific data specifically gene
expression data and the most natural
first step annotation is just a tissue
sample is it a liver cell is it a kidney
cell and there is a project spearheaded
by Chuck Zuckerberg initiative that
tries to actually build a human cell
Atlas so it's a very important problem
and we have a lot of data collected
already on legacy technologies in those
repositories and want annotated well so
you might ask that this we can just
search that this reporter has a search
bar what happens if you type things in
that search bar well in turns out that
precision and recall are pretty low so
if you search for liver only half less
than half of the stuff that you get out
is actual liver and so on
so let's formulate the problem a little
bit more concretely so we have a
repository that contains a bunch of
samples each sample a each data item
consists of a data sample which for
expression data sets you can think of as
a vector of 20,000 real values and then
there's also often a text description so
people are uploading the
data items into the poster for other
people's to use so they describe those
items those descriptions can vary in
accuracy sometimes the description will
explicitly mention the tissue sometimes
like an example on the right it will be
more cryptic well it will use some
abbreviations in another cases it will
be completely missing and to point out
we now know about 5000 different human
tissues in the predefined anthology in
science and more and more different cell
types have been discovered every day
with advances and technologists like
single-cell sequencing also phrenology
I'm going to show a results of our
approach on a different data set from
Project called vision metrics which is a
project that tries to look into
scientific images and tries to classify
figures from scientific papers in two
different types into different
visualization types well the most
natural thing to do is data annotation
is just a classification so you have a
classifier you can and it you can get
labels and your problem is solved so
what's the bottleneck here well the
bottom line is that you have to you have
to find labeled data somewhere say you
labeled a bunch of samples yourself or
so you somehow got label data and in
this case you label bar chart and fight
shard but then you will miss you will
inevitably miss the samples in the
longer tail like in this particular case
you will miss a phylogenetic tree maybe
a picture of a platypus
or something like that and where do we
get that label data to begin with you
can crowdsource it but even in a figure
annotation example explaining people on
the Mechanical Turk the type of
visualization or type of this
visualization might be complicated and
if you want to ask them to annotate
thousands different human tissue samples
so it's gonna be hopeless so you have to
either hire expensive experts do to
yourself so this is kind of a bottleneck
of this approach there are smarter
tricks so there is a paper and nips last
year of two years ago on data
programming where you write labeling
functions we
produce you know easy heuristic labels
and different different labeling
functions can produce different labels
for the same sample and then they have a
framework to produce a training dataset
out of those labeling functions or you
can use your short learning so the read
learning approaches would allow you to
skip labeling some of the classes but
that kind of assumes that you have
labels for other related classes and you
know the structure of your label space
so what we are going to do is we're
going to take advantage of our specific
problem formulation and introduce an
approach called easy learn and
specifically what we observe and the
problem they were working with is
presence of this organic supervision
organic supervision we define it as two
components first component is a lexicon
so each label that we're trying to
predict this not just an abstract entity
it actually contains it actually
contains an English word let represents
this it's it's a liver it has we know
the word liver and then in Sciences we
actually have those anthologies where we
might have some synonyms for liver not
actually also no names but some of the
synonyms for different classes and also
people who produce this data they would
have text descriptions sometimes the
most of them that will be pretty noisy
but occasionally they would mention an
original text original term by name so
for example in the figure comprehension
case this caption of this particular
image explicitly mentioned that this is
a scatterplot so to use this information
we introduced an approach we call easier
which composition combines distance
supervision and code training so we use
distance supervision which is an idea of
using this extra information for
ontology and Texas caption to find us
initial set of labels and then we
trained an axillary classifier that
works in a text domain in predicts a
label and that output of the classifier
used to train a main cause the main
classifier from the original data domain
so gene expression data or figure figure
values classifiers we use a pretty
simple so we don't want to
that you need to have sophisticated
classifiers have linear regression for
the data domain after some future
transformations and then we use fast
text for the text domain and so before
we evaluate lets me describe the tasks
in a little finer detail so we have over
a hundred thousand gene expression
samples in the repository that we're
looking at there are almost 5000
different tissue types that we want to
predict each on average those samples
have descriptions that mention three and
half different labels so we have this
set of noisy labels and on the other end
of the spectrum for images we have over
a million images we have a growing
anthology of figure types that we are
coming up with more and more types that
we want to annotate every time but then
most of the captions don't explicitly
mention the figure type and so also for
evaluation because we have because we
have an anthology that we are trying to
predict labels from we want to take
advantage of the ontology at the
evaluation step as well so we're using
ontology based precision and recall
where we propagate labels from a correct
prediction and from sorry from the
correct label and from predicted label
up to the root of the ontology and then
measure precision and recall in a
standard way this allows us to capture
differences between being almost right
and being close to right and being
completely far off and so looking at the
tissue annotation example we compared
with the previous state-of-the-art
approach there to a strain on 15,000
manually both the data samples it's
called your essay and looking at the
area under precision recall curve we
significant outperform this previous
approach we also see that if we use a
coup iam a variant of code training
using their 15,000 samples we get
improvement so the advantage here is
that URIs a just used their 15,000
samples a cou iam would use that 15,000
label samples and then about a hundred
thousand of the rest of the samples they
don't have explicit labels but it would
iterate and improve the labels I ensures
that actually if you have
access to that entire repository and
just do distance supervision you do
pretty well and then your say is and
then either learn is being a combination
of distance supervision and qem does
better than either of those showing that
both components are important so this is
yeah you can see it so those are
personal recall curves for tushy
annotation example on the left and
figure comprehension example on the
right and in blue is our method in red
this previous state-of-the-art approach
and Green Dot is what you get if you
just search using distance essentially
distance supervision also we want to
investigate why exactly that happens on
the right we vary the amount of
unlabeled were very amount of data
without explicit labels that we feed
into either easy learn or Co M and we
see that even though Kui M can improve
with more unlabeled data
I either learn improvement is
significantly higher and then we can see
that the problem happens because you've
learned picks up those cases from a
longer tail with more training data with
more unlabeled training data and so to
conclude these learn combines distance
supervision and Co training to allow you
to solve a problem in this organic
supervision regime where you have a
bunch of data that was put in the
repository without any machine readable
labels but there are human readable
labels that sometimes contain relevant
information for you so you don't have to
label the data you can just do this code
training pass distance supervision
approach and it's also very useful for
cases where you have change in ontology
or grow in anthologies if you want to
find in you but you know biologists who
maintain an ontology of tissues add
another tissue type in the ontology we
can just see around the method without
actually finding manual label third
particular tissue yeah thanks questions
[Applause]